so with all this experience i think it's
uh very important to have a sense of
community
for the human development in any area
that you work in anything that you do
and particularly in this field that we
are at
the the bioinformatics field it is also
important to teach kids and adults
computational concepts because it's a
form of investment
in their lives as we said i come from
an undergraduate background where i
didn't have any exposure to
uh computational programming so it's uh
really important to provide
people with that type of training in a
field of science that in my
uh in my mind and i guess many of you
would agree with me is so needed these
days
so for many of us uh and for me
particularly a computational algorithm
is a thing that
i never use it to think five
years ago for instance before before
that i never use it to really think
about what a computational algorithm is
but really today i would like to give
you a very
uh general idea of what a computational
algorithm is it is a basically a set of
rules
uh to be followed in calculations to
obtain
uh results from uh as an
an output from a given input so you
basically have
some sort some piece of data you give it
to
a computational algorithm and you get a
result out of it
and thank you alia so much because you
talked about this concept of
falsification how it is so important in
cancer and in these
advanced genomic studies but really
i like to start from the very uh
simple principles of of science
and i guess we have been using these
some sort of pacification for a really
really long time here
this example of classifying for instance
animals
so we can for instance think about
pacifying the animals based on their
number of
feet and i hope i'm saying that
correctly in english
so here we have animals with two feet
and here we have those animals with four
feets and this is a
system of clustering or classification
like we
we could argue that uh in that in that
regard uh
classification system like classifying
animals by their species
is a more refined way of classification
uh compared to clustering but really we
are talking about
uh grouping subgroups
based on similarities that they have
so how can we get started with this
computational classification i would say
that we are so interested in
first i would say it is really really
important to
identify a problem as i am going to tell
you the problem that i work with
is cancer particularly neuroblastoma
which is a
pediatric cancer
the other thing that i would say is
important is to identify
a sponsor so a mentor a school
or a group a science group that you
might be interested in
and uh really the
what you need is someone or an
institution that has the potential
to guide you through the process and
frankly
i joined omixlogic a couple of weeks ago
i'm still
getting used to all the resources that
they have but
so far i think the resources that i have
seen and have
tested and use it they they're very very
available resources in the
bioinformatics field
so i said that it's important to
identify a problem that you're
interested in and the one that i
told you i am interested in is
neuroblastoma it's a complex
or polygenic disease i'll not go
too much into details but i want to say
that it's
a problem in the development of the
sympathetic
nervous system so the sympathetic
nervous system is this part of the
nervous system that connects organs to
the central nervous system here
in the spine for instance as you can see
the other problem that i want to go to
in neuroblastoma
is this concept that we have two major
populations in the tumor so we have
the whole mass of the tumor
there we could argue that there are many
subpopulations but
i am going to talk tell you about the
two main subgroups the two major
populations which are the
population of adrenergic cells that look
actually like neurons that's why you see
these projections from the cytoplasm of
the cells
making them really look like neurons and
we have them using camel cells
which do not have these progression at
these projections
they are not they do not adhere sorry
they adhere very tightly
to substrate that's why they have this
name of s-type which means substrate
adherent but the difference between
these cells is that the adrenergic cells
are really differentiated
and the mesenchymal cells are not
differentiated
you can also think of them as cells with
a
stem stemness potential very high
so these mesenchymal cells are not
differentiated
they are not sensitive to chemotherapy
they do not die upon chemotherapy
and they lead to this concept of minimal
residual disease
which is the concept that after you give
chemotherapy treatment to
the cells the chemotherapy is going to
kill the adrenergic cells but not the
mesenchymal
and the mesenchymal cells have the
ability to differentiate into
adrenergic cells and that there we have
a problem because
the chemotherapy is not going to kill
the cells and so there is a chance that
the disease
is going to come back and when the
disease progresses or relapses
there is an enrichment of the
mesenchymal cells
it is really important to classify
neuroblastoma tumors and i'm going to
give you a more detailed idea of what
that looks like
it's really important to classify the
tumors into
adrenergic mesenchymal because that has
a
potential for prognosis but so far
i mean that's the part of research that
i do here this
slide shows you what really the ultimate
level
of uh prognosis is in neuroblastoma
so uh neuroblastoma tumor is really
classified
uh into high risk and non-high-risk
neuroglastoma so the high risk
has a very lower survival probability
compared to
non-high risk and really one
important problem is that after a child
is the tumor of a child is a classified
as a highly
risk neuroglostonic there are no methods
to determine whether
that disease will progress or not
so measuring as i said the mesenchymal
cells may provide prognostic ability to
the research
and mesenchymal cell quantification can
be done by sequencing
of epigenetic profiles
so clustering consists on the
identification of homogeneous groups
among a set of heterogeneous items
in the specific case of neuroblastoma
what i
try what i do is i classify cell lines
or tumors based on their gene expression
profiles
the other thing that i have worked it
with is classification of
sars cov2 surface v2
based on their mutational profiles you
would agree with me that mutations are
important in cancer and are also
important in
orbit 19. so for neuroblastoma
this is an example of what's going on
right now in the field because
what people try to do is to classify
these adrenergic cells
and the mesenchymal cells this is a
machine learning method called
hierarchical clustering
so we can basically separate classify or
clusterize
the adrenergic and mesenchymal cells you
can do the same
using what what are called wet lab
methods
such as a western blot this is a
biochemical method of protein
quantification
and you can use some scoring systems
to classify adrenergic and mesenchymal
cells based
also on their gene expression profiles
this image here in the
right is a similar method this is also a
hierarchical clustering method but this
is based
on uh enhancer enhancer peaks or enhance
cis regulatory regions um the enhancer
regions that we use to
classify or differentiate the adrenergic
and mesenchymal cells
so what i do currently is i
basically score tumors so what you see
here in the left
are 498 tumors
classified with a high mesenchymal score
top high second highest mesenchymal
highest mesenchymal score third highest
missing
most core and fourth highest mesenchymal
score which is the basically the lowest
missing chemical scores
and what we can demonstrate or see
is that as tumors with high amazing
chemospores they have
a lower survival probability here i am
looking at all risks
but there is some evidence that when i
look at the high risk of work
that cohort also has a lower survival
probability and so this is
showing some evidence that the
classification
of tumors based on their epigenetic
profiles may allow
uh some prognosis analysis in high-risk
neuroblastoma and this is very important
because as i said
for high-risk neuroblastoma there's no
such a prognosis system yet
and that's what we're working with so i
am
going to and now my talk by showing you
one thing that is really interesting in
my opinion which is the fact that we can
compare
these very different types of diseases
on the right i have
a heat map of um neuroblastoma this is
using the
uh rnac profile of neuroblastoma
sorry if i said this is the left this is
the right the right image
the la in the left side here we have a
heat map
showing the mutational profile of covet
19.
so with the high school students that i
told you we
developed these classification system
of covid19 based on the mutational
profiles
so here what's interesting to note is
that by looking at the frequency of
these mutations we see
some sort of clusterization of the
mutations that are
in the extreme or extreme east
of the earth such as
the samples collected from china also
present
in the bat and the penguin which which
are thought to be the animals
that are um more prominent hosts
of of the virus so really here what i
want to say
is that a computational biology methods
allow us to compare
or to uh have a sense of common analysis
that can be done in in two completely
different diseases such as neuroblastoma
and covid19 so in conclusion
as i said bioinformatics can be used to
study and understand these
two very different diseases and many
other types of different diseases as
we saw in during this presentation
and more specifically in my case
bioinformatics may allow the development
of prognosis system for
high risk near blossom so i would like
to end now
thank you so much for listening